jordan peterson has returned to the
public eye
after a very long hiatus due to as far
as i understand it
being in a detox clinic in russia in
order to get off of benzodiazepine
benzodiazepines that he became addicted
to including being in a medically
induced coma for some period of time
then peterson going from russia to
serbia for further treatment eventually
getting kovid 19 but now he's back
and he's getting back to the interview
circuit and he's already saying really
dangerous things now
i'm going to talk about one of the
things he said during an interview
with brett weinstein and i know i'm
stepping into a minefield here
the tricky thing about talking about the
things jordan peterson says is that no
matter what his most devoted
followers will say david you're
misquoting him you're misunderstanding
him
so even if it appears as though jordan
peterson said something that was wrong
or wacky
or dangerous you were the one who
doesn't get it david you were
strawmanning him
but what jordan peterson said is quite
dangerous and i think it's important to
talk about it but i will
admit that in this clip we're going to
look at
peterson uses sort of interchangeable
and sometimes vague terminology
so first we have to figure out what it
is that he is saying but the general
message from peterson here is
medicine may be responsible for
killing more people than the number of
people that medicine
saves uh again that's what i'm hearing
let's listen to the clip then i suspect
if you did these statistics properly i
suspect that
that medicine independent of public
health kills more people than it saves
i suspect if you if you factor in
phenomena like the development of
superbugs in hospitals for example
that overall the net consequence of
hospitals is negative
now that's just a guess and but it's and
and it could easily be
wrong but it it also could not be wrong
and that is a good example or that's
where my thinking about what we don't
know has taken me
with regards to the critique of what we
do
the fact that it's even plausible is a
stunning
well you know medical error is the third
leading cause of death
yeah you know and that doesn't take into
account
the generation of superbugs for example
so
there is a lot there but a key quote
here for what we're dealing with is
jordan peterson saying
i suspect that medicine independent of
public health
kills more people than it saves that's
the main point and this includes
as he says the fact that in hospitals
sometimes people get infections
and medical error and that if you
include all of that
he believes it's possible that medicine
actually kills more people than it saves
now unfortunately this is not plausible
this is a completely absurd idea and in
particular when we have nearly half the
country
doubting the seriousness of covid
because of the nonsense spread by the
right for a year
and a huge contingent of covet
anti-vaxxers that we have to contend
with
this is a particularly dangerous time to
be making completely wild
implausible claims about medicine let's
take it piece by piece
first of all medicine killing more
people than it saves is ridiculous
now he says aside from public health
so i'll exclude vaccination from this
because he's kind of saying
we're putting aside public health he's
not saying that
you know if you include public health
initiatives like clean water vaccination
he's saying we're not including that in
his calculation
um think about the sheer number of
people like think about yourself
from the time you were a little kid ear
infection
sinus infection things that before
antibiotics
would kill many people now they don't
thanks to being able
to go to a doctor be diagnosed and get
antibiotics
dentistry the number of people that used
to die because of problems that start
with the
teeth including how teeth problems
create malnutrition where you can't eat
never mind infections in the mouth
modern dentistry including fixing
cavities how many people have been saved
by that
how many people are saved by heart
bypasses in the united states each each
year
who would otherwise die 500 000
heart bypasses in the united states
every single year
very few uh have a medical error related
deaths associated with them just to pick
i mean we could go through all day
10 000 cases of testicular cancer each
year which
medicine treats with a 95 success rate
that's hospitals
that's medicine saving people and he
actually says in the clip
you know i really don't have any idea
about this but he has such a cult of
devoted followers that now
they will take this and they will run
with it peterson
also talked about medical error
as the third leading cause of death
medical error is
a problem without a doubt but comparing
it to all the people saved by medicine
and it should also be mentioned that
medical error has been dramatically
overstated and when good
studies look at it medical error is not
nearly as bad as some like to claim
now there is malpra malpractice there is
medical error
of course but a yale school of medicine
study found that the real number of
truly
preventable deaths in the u.s in
inpatients is about
twenty two thousand you sometimes hear
numbers like forty thousand
to a hundred thousand sometimes you hear
two hundred and fifty thousand
that's the number that is sometimes used
to say it's the third leading
cause of death this study suggests that
the number of
otherwise healthy people who died just
because of medical error
could be as low as 7 100 and that the
rest
of the preventable slash medical error
deaths
are in people with a life expectancy of
three months very sick people now that
doesn't make their deaths any less
tragic
it doesn't mean we don't deal with
malpractice and hold people accountable
but the point is we're talking about
people who in a perfect world have three
months to live
whose care may have been mismanaged in a
way that could have robbed them of time
it's no less tragic i get it but the
idea of an epidemic of
otherwise healthy people just dying from
medical error
it's quite rare in the united states the
leading causes
of death in the united states are
mostly particular types of disease
including cancer or others
accidents including car accidents okay
this type of stuff
from jordan peterson will make some
people
more hesitant to get care to get
vaccines
and in the end peterson again admits he
actually has no
idea but he believes it's plausible it's
really not
plausible based on anything i was able
to find about it
so the big news is that jordan peterson
is back everybody
for better or worse make of it what you
will
friday march 26th one day membership
special
we're blowing out memberships it's a
vaccination related membership special
if you would like to get a membership at
an ungodly discounted rate
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
friday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly
how to avail yourselves of this
immorally cheap
membership discount that we're offering
one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off a one year plan
which is less than six bucks a month
when you go to davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10 off
when you use the code pacman